[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
aujourd'hui la loi fait la distribution
alimentaire là on revient vers la
population en situation de précarité
d'isolement on vient apporter l'aide
alimentaire
offert par la croix-rouge et et ses
partenaires ses eaux plates un petit
village rural des hauts de saint leu que
se rendent ces bénévoles de la croix
rouge seront sur place ils distribueront
des colis alimentaires des familles
défavorisées en situation d'isolement
aller à la rencontre de ces personnes
c'est pour la croix rouge un moyen de
recréer du lien social avec ces familles
et lutter contre la pauvreté de la
stratégie de prévention et de lutte
contre la pauvreté
nous sommes présents dans divers
ateliers et nous déployons et avons
présenté un projet et d'un dispositif
d'aller vers toujours avec des objectifs
spécifiques différents qui sont à la
fois des objectifs pour apporter de
l'aide matérielle aide alimentaire et
vestimentaire mais aussi de lutter
contre l'illettrisme mais aussi de
pouvoir apporter d'autres services
puisque le dispositif de croix rouge
seront peut nous permettre de mettre à
disposition des écrivains publics peut
nous permettre d'être dans une démarche
d'accueil écoute et d'accompagner des
gens pour favoriser leur inclusion
sociale tout dispositif d'aller vers est
un dispositif d'inclusion sociale et
dans ce cadre là on lutte contre la
pauvreté
nous sommes ici à montvert les bas dans
le sud de l'île dans l'un des cinq
entrepôts de la banque alimentaire des
mascareignes
ce réseau associatif gère chaque année
près de 900 tonnes de denrées
alimentaires à destination de personnes
en difficultés celui là aujourd'hui il
est composée très majoritairement plus
de 70 % de personnes qui sont
bénéficiaires du rsa ou de personnes qui
sont au chômage
parmi ce public là on s'aperçoit de plus
en plus on a des personnes de plus de 60
ans on s'aperçoit également que sur les
véhicules et on a de plus en plus de
jeunes de moins de 15 ans qu'ils sont
en difficulté en termes de carences
alimentaires et fait relativement
nouveau
quand je dis nouveau salah de trois ans
à peu près là aussi on n'en commence à
voir des personnes qui travaillent dans
un ménage bio - un revenu les colis
alimentaires préparés par ces bénévoles
alimenteront un réseau de 42 partenaires
qui distribueront gratuitement ces
denrées sous forme de colis alimentaires
de repas et au sein d épicerie sociale
et solidaire tous nos partenaires ont
pour obligation en plus de donner ses
produits alimentaires de faire un
travail d'accueil et d'accompagnement
social des publics qui sont concernés
par cette aide alimentaire la demande
sociale augmente elle augmente d'année
en année
sur les trois dernières années nous nous
constatons une augmentation de l'ordre
de 10% de la demande se servir dans
cette épicerie sociale et solidaire au
tampon 600 colis alimentaires sont
distribués chaque mois les bénéficiaires
peuvent également acheter ici des
produits de consommation courante vendus
entre 10 et 20% de leur valeur marchande
la balle c'est être en dessous du seuil
des 7 975 euros
1950 pour faire pour un ordinaire et
sont à l'heure actuelle qu on aide avec
la
hong lei a ré apprendre à gérer son
budget faire quelque chose faire en
sorte que le corps qui arrive à la fin
du mois ils ont ils ont ils ont encore
quelque chose le comte l'année dernière
52 mille repas et 25 mille colis
alimentaires ont été distribuées pour
venir en aide aux trois cent mille
personnes vivent sous le seuil de
pauvreté à la réunion
[Musique]